in the next half an hour we'll see
what's making headlines with the
political correspondent for the
financial times Jasmine Cameron chileche
and with the format number 10
speechwriter ASA Bennetts now let's take
a look at what's on some of those front
pages and we'll start with the front
page of the Observer which says that
hospital trusts are frantically trying
to fill gaps left by striking Junior
doctors ahead of four days of industrial
action next week
the Sunday Times says it secures timers
labor party will continue its ruthless
campaigning the papers says that labor
will accuse the prime minister of
effectively decriminalizing rape
the Sunday Telegraph has the leader of
the Scottish conservatives telling
supporters to vote for labor to house
the SMP the call has reportedly caused
some anger from Tori party HQ in London
the Sunday Mirror hears from the mother
of Olivia Pratt Corbell shell who says
she will fight the gun and gang culture
that led to the death of her daughter
the Sunday Express claims the coronation
will distract from what is expected to
be a nightmare set of local election
results for the conservatives the paper
dicks the Tories could lose a thousand
Council seats
and the mail on Sunday claims King
Charles is at odds with the church over
his desire for a diverse coronation
while the sun on Sunday says S Club 7
Star Paul catamol reportedly told the
fan he was going to smash it on the
group's 25th anniversary door the day
before he died
and a reminder by scanning the QR code
that you see on your screen during this
program you can watch along with us and
check the front pages as we discuss them
as I said tonight we're joined by
Jasmine Cameron cheleshe and Acer
Bennett and there they are in the big
screen good evening to both of you guys
thank you so much for giving up your
Saturday night to talk to us let's get
straight into it Jasmine and start with
the Observer and that Junior doctor
strike that's taking place next week's
really going to dominate the news agenda
four days of action and it could be the
biggest set of strikes that we've seen
yeah so the Observer focuses on some of
the tactics being deployed by NHS trusts
to really reduce the impacts of the the
four-day strike action that is planned
for next week it talks about the fact
that some healthy patients will you know
could be discharged early
um stop NHS workers may be asked to
cancel leave and there is a real feeling
of trepidation about these strikes
because we know that it comes at a time
where the NHS is still reeling from the
impacts of the pandemic the impact of
the seasonal winter pressures and also
the impacts of ongoing strike action
that we've seen over the past few months
and I think you know we know that the
government has made some Headway with
the NHS strikes and that and say for
example the Royal College of Nursing
they're currently weighing up an offer
put forward by the government but
obviously there's still a lot of back
and forth between the BMA who represent
Junior doctors and the government over
any potential pay deal and that's why
these strikes are still going ahead and
think it puts the government in a very
challenging position because yes these
strikes have been going on for a long
time but I think there is a general
understanding and acceptance that
actually NHS workers perform a vital
service and anyone that's gone to their
local supermarket can see that despite
government claims that inflation will be
um down by the end of the year you go
into your Supermarket you see prices are
still high energy bills are still high
and I think people do recognize that NHS
NHS workers particularly Junior doctors
who are some of the lowest paid are
actually going through you know are
really impacted by inflation and the
current economic circumstances so I
think it will be interesting to see how
the government reacts to the next week's
strikes how individual NHS trusts are
able to react and what impacts that will
have on the running of the service yeah
it certainly will be a later I mean the
the ask as we know from Junior doctors
from the bmas were 35 pay increase to
make up for some 16 years of which they
say was a low inflation increases and
one of the interesting lines out of this
Observer article is that um Consultants
who uh I think last time stepped in to
take some of the workload that Junior
doctors left when they were striking in
their last strike are being threatened
um with pay cut so they don't actually
take on that workload this time
well yes I think it shows that NHS
managers are taking the gloves off in
terms of trying to
you know take a neural no-nonsense
approach
um to keep the things to Turning as much
as possible yet we know from the same
article that there's going to be you
know I think it's estimated a quarter
million appointments
um you're disrupted forcibly delayed
canceled
um and this speaks to the scale of you
know chaos that will ensue inevitably
because of the junior doctors and the
role they play across the service how
important their work is and so by
withdrawing it
um the you know scale of the spanner
that they're throwing in the works
um and yes as you say they are asking in
order to effectively keep Pace with
inflation and the cost of living
um 35 uh pay Rise
um the governments make their day view
that as unsustainable unacceptable
um given the effect of its sort of blank
check and labor interestingly
um you know while it has made it
instinctively it backs the cause the
West streeting a shadow Health secretary
has made he does not not think the BMA
are right to us for 35 so there isn't
really a political consensus
um behind what the BMA is pushing for
yet we know from the recent payoff that
was put on the table for NHS staff
across the board that was a if memory
serves as much as eight percent
um so it was some way when I think they
were asking for a bit more than that but
you know striking has worked recently so
with all the tough talk it never
there'll be some sort of compromise
negotiators will be dragged back to the
table yeah especially if the service
completely collapses for the four dates
that the strike action has taken place
all right let's keep moving on guys okay
so I'm going to stick with you when we
look at the front page of the Sunday
Times now and of course the story that's
been making a lot of headlines the past
week is uh what seems to be a new labor
party tactic paper here describes it as
being ruthless in their dirty tricks
heading up to the next election just hey
so just talk us through the reporting
here Sunday and times habit
yeah basically labor has been studying
how elections have been won in America
and Australia their conclusion is that
that they are not afraid to really get
stuck in and sling mud
um and you know for too long I think
labors felt that they've you know tried
to be keep the higher ground and
um have been doing so lose elections
um while the Tories have been able to
really sort of uh be not pull punches
and attack labor in all sorts of ways
and then come away with it so is it
better to be you sort of get dirty as a
result well in this case kirstan was
quite happy too in this sense because
they're putting out attack ads with
Rishi sunak's face and signature on it
effectively trying to ask voters in this
first round of their campaign
um you know basically do you accept the
that adults convicted sexually
assaulting children should go to prison
while Rishi soon act does not there's so
many issues with this factual and all
the rest that people have been chewing
over for the last few days
um and even the Tories and others have
pointed out that actually the only
person the only political leader who had
a real say on what the sentencing you
know Arrangements was back then was
kierstava who sat on the sentencing
Council as director of public
prosecutions so there's all sorts of
niggles and ways to start to unravel but
I think the kind of trump style theory
behind it is that if we're talking about
it the more we try and fact check it the
more people that are hearing perhaps
that Rishi sunak is soft on crime and so
the purpose okay to be the mess you're
getting is that you know kirst wanting
to follow this up by saying that you
know the Tories affect me are doing
decriminalizing rape so lots of
inflammatory stuff this will only build
as we get in their election time yes
anyway and just anecdotally I did hear
this exact discussion being had in the
barbershop today with the advert being
talked about by the guys there I mean uh
Jasmine just just follow on with this
because there's another story we're
going to come to later but just on that
idea about the sort of the ruthlessness
of the labor party I mean the question I
guess will be for some labor supporters
whether or not they'll be able to
stomach their ruthlessness if it gets
them wins
to point out that actually in previous
years and months there's been a feeling
in some labor circles that perhaps they
by taking the quote-unquote high road
that actually they've allowed the
conservatives to dominate The Narrative
on certain topics and I think in
particular when it comes to the issue of
Criminal Justice and crime I think the
labor party are really Keen to put their
stamp on it and present this narrative
to the public that after 12 or 13 years
of the conservative government they've
underfunded local services and
effectively meant that certain crimes be
that rape or burglary have been
effectively decriminalized in this
country now as you say whether or not
that approach goes down well with labor
activists and whether or not they get
the tone right is a different question
but I do think this does Mark A a shift
in in tactics being deployed by the
labor party and I think we should
actually expect to see more and more of
this as we move into the local elections
and the general election because this is
a party that's been opposite in in
opposition for more than a decade now
the hungry for power they can you know
they feel like it's within their grass
they're looking at the poles and they
are willing to do whatever it takes to
to get the attention of the public now
whether the tone is correct or whether
that feeds well with um potential labor
voters or activists well I think we'll
have to wait and see Jasmine just a
quick thought from you as well on this
on the front of the Observer same story
but the fact that there seems to be some
disagreement within the party on the the
use of these kind of ads I mean what's
that potentially going to do do you
think
um I mean I think it's quite interesting
because when it was first
um when it first came out I think they
had the party tried to put forward a
unified Voice Within in the subsequent
days you we've seen this briefing
there's been a sense that perhaps not
all those on the The Shadow front bench
were in agreement I do think
I do think it speaks the fact that the
party is still navigating what language
and tone to use and how to get its
messaging across the public and I think
this perhaps will be written off as a
gaffe and maybe they will make sure all
Shadow members are fully on board before
they put out messaging but I think yeah
it just speaks of a party trying to
figure out what its messages and how to
communicate that in an effective way to
the public and they say we haven't got
loads of time left but you were nodding
along to some of that and obviously
you've advised on these kind of things
on how to do
these kind of comms this kind of
communication with uh with adverts I
mean do you think that the what looks to
be a divide between some parts of the
party could be quite a problematic for
the labor party
oh absolutely I mean frankly it's just
sloppy work by labor given that when you
have the shadow Home Secretary about
Cooper who's meant to be responsible for
some of this messaging you know
disowning it
um you know it's a bit shambolic and
crucially they've forgotten that you
know yes Trump and vote Lee were very
bombastic and grabbed attention with
their campaigning but they were thrilled
to perfection in their messaging they
knew what to say they did not squirm at
all under Fire unlike neighbor hello
there and welcome back you are watching
The Press preview with me are the
political correspondent for the
financial times Jasmine Cameron
chileshay and the former number 10
speechwriter ASA Bennett and they're
going to stay with us throughout Stephen
let's get back into the papers and we'll
start with the front of the Sunday
Telegraph and Jasmine let's start with
you on this one and it's uh politics
again and this is um
as a bit of a bizarre comment coming
from the leader of the conservatives in
Scotland just talk us through this
reporting if you can
yes so this is the leader of the
Scottish conservatives Douglas Ross has
seemingly given has spoken to the Sunday
Telegraph where he appears to have
encouraged Tories in Scotland to vote
tactically in the upcoming elections is
essentially said that
um you know he's encouraged voters to do
what's best for the country and in a
case where
um it looks like it could be potential
SMP labor-facing seat to to vote for
labor party which is quite a quite a
striking thing to say and it's quite
interesting if you read further down the
Sunday Telegraph article his words seem
to have been contradicted by tour
resources in London who have
categorically stated that that is not
the party's policy and I think it comes
at this really interesting time in
Scottish politics where we're seeing
that the SMP which held a large
dominance in the region that dominance
seems to be shaking slightly with the
departure of Nicholas sturgeon and the
arrest of her her husband and I think
actually going you know looking ahead to
the general in particular I think we
will be hearing more about tactical
voting and whether that's lib Dems and
you know between the live dance and
labor party whether that's SMP and
tories I think all parties will be
looking quite cynically at the electoral
map and thinking where can we
realistically win and will be you know
perhaps not making comments as bold as
Douglas Ross has said in a Sunday
Telegraph but there will be these these
discussions in party H quarters of of
headquarters of of where they should be
encouraging their voters to to vote and
how best they can hold on to power in
their respective regions and they said
what did you make of this when you read
it because of course it's worth
remembering that um the labor party
desperately need to come back in
Scotland so it does strike me it's
interesting that Douglas Ross will be
saying this
absolutely
um basically if kirst armor is going to
become the next prime minister then
labor needs to win big it needs to come
back in a really huge way in Scotland
that requires an overturning of the S
P's Stranglehold on the Holly route so
that is why I can really understand that
Tory HQ in London would have basically
freaked out about their Scottish toy
leader
um suggesting uh that maybe votes for
labor could work for the wider reason of
getting the s p out
um however at the same time I can sort
of understand where Douglas Ross is
coming from because you know he can he
can read the same polls that we can all
see he knows that not everyone who is
following what he says would
instinctively and may or decide to vote
Tori and so I think he's then trying to
say that if you are not going to vote
Tori then consider anyone else who is
best place to beat the SNP because after
all you know the Tories have been able
to be the opposition under some people
like Ruth Davidson so this is I think
the best they can really aim for in
Scotland
okay guys let's move on to the front of
the mail and some stories I want to get
to about the coronation and mail uh ASAP
uh what tells us that Charles's at odds
with the church because he wants a
diverse coronation what are the details
in this
well basically it's all about and the
details are being kept very closely on
the wraps so bugging Palace and Lambeth
Palace together are refusing to confirm
anything but what we understand from the
reports is it's all about you know how
Charles's idea of being a sort of King
for Multicultural multi-faith Britain
will play out
um the idea that effectively the king is
meant to be you know head of the Church
of England but and defender of the faith
he has said before that he quite
fantasies the idea of being the defender
of faith in general
um you know is reflecting the many
religions and Creeds that exist in this
country
um and so basically how do they Square
this all the Constitutional questions
that may have to be played out on this
um these are all being done behind
closed doors so we'll have to see and of
course it's only a few more weeks until
this thing has to be finalized and as
part of it there's been order of service
put together
um which will lay out a lot of the
procedure about this so we await with
baited breath yeah we're gonna find out
pretty soon as you say and Jasmine
um I mean this is interesting that this
is all about the order of service
because as ASA said Charles has wanted
to be as diverse as possible and when
the coronation when the invitation was
released a few days ago there was a lot
of chatter on social media about the
Green Man being at the very center of it
the Pagan symbol which a lot of people
online were saying is a sign of how
Charles is trying to be as ASA said you
know a protector of faith
foreign
yeah so I think the the monarchy under
King Charles is in a really interesting
place and that it's trying to balance
the need for tradition and Heritage with
also the need to adapt to modern society
and ultimately for the monarchy to
survive it needs to be an institution
that people of all faiths Races and
classes can look at and you know feel
engaged but I feel interested in and I
think the story really gets to the heart
of that tension of of what kind of king
um King Charles wants to be and what he
wants the monarchy to look to look like
under him and you know obviously we'll
get more details um at a later date but
I think the fact that this has even been
briefed and has come out on the front
page is quite interesting and speaks to
you know the fact that King Charles is
very much still figuring out
what it means to be king and and what he
wants this institution to to look like
yeah certainly okay last thought from
you then later we're going to look at
the Sunday Express and uh
align here there headline King to rescue
Rishi just quickly we've only got about
a minute left just to tell us what this
is about
basically he's not getting he's not
waiting into politics and in fact it's
just that the coronation will happen in
the wake of the local elections which
are widely expected to be basically
electoral blood bar for the Tories and
so it will be very helpful for the Prime
Minister because then people will not be
paying attention to that so much so they
will instead be basking and singing God
Save the King and busy focusing and
uniting and coming together for such an
occasion uh Jasmine you're smoking at
that I mean the idea that TV won't be
paying any attention to the uh potential
shellacking that the Tory is going to
get the local elections is probably not
quite true
yeah I was quite curious by the framing
because if as the the paper is
suggesting that the conservatives lose
you know around a thousand seats I mean
that's certainly going to be used to you
know newspapers and TV and I'm sure
we'll all be talking about it so despite
the coronation we definitely will all
right Jazz love to talk to you guys both